[Music]
as the April Sun rises on a pile of
firewood somethingroyal
stirs inside this wasp queen is one of
thousands who made it in late autumn and
hibernated through the winter
now she emerges into the spring air to
begin her reign most of her sisters
weren't so lucky
while hibernating in compost piles and
underground burrows many sleeping queens
were eaten by spiders warm winters
caused by climate change
led other Queens to emerge early only to
find there was no available food and
some queens that survived the winter
fell victim to the threats of spring
such as carnivorous plants birds and
man-made pesticides our queen is the
lone survivor of her old hive and now
she must become the foundress of a new
one but first breakfast the Queen heads
for a citrus grove full of honey bee
hives the bees can be dangerous if
provoked but right now they're paralyzed
by the morning cold their hairy bodies
are dripping with sugar water from an
earlier feeding and the resourceful
queen licks them for a morning snack
newly energized our queen searches for a
safe nesting area this tree hollow safe
from rain wind and predators is ideal
she choose the surrounding wood and
plant fibers to make a paper like pulp
then she builds around 50 brood cells
that comprised the beginning of her nest
using sperms stored from last fall the
Queen lays a fertilized egg into each
cell producing as many as 12 in 20
minutes within a week these will hatch
into female larvae but until then the
Queen must hunt down smaller insects to
feed her brood all while expanding the
hive laying eggs and defending against
intruders
fortunately our queen is well-prepared
unlike bees wasps can sting as many
times as they need to
with such a busy schedule the Queen
barely has time to feed herself luckily
she doesn't have to when she feeds an
insect to her grubs they digest the bug
into a sugary substance that sustains
their mother by the end of July
these first larvae have matured into
adult workers ready to take on foraging
building and defense the Queen can now
lay eggs full-time sustaining herself on
her workers spoils and their
unfertilized eggs although each worker
only lives for roughly three weeks the
Queen's continuous egg-laying swells
their ranks in just one summer the nest
reaches the size of a basketball
supporting thousands of workers such a
large population needs to eat and the
nearby garden provides a veritable
buffet as the swarm descends alarmed
humans try to swat them they even fight
back with pesticides that purposefully
poisoned wasps and inadvertently impact
a wide range of local wildlife but the
wasps are actually vital to this
ecosystem sitting at the top of the
local invertebrate food chain these
insects keep spiders mites and
centipedes in check
wasps consume crop eating insects making
them particularly helpful for farms and
Gardens
they even pollinate fruits and
vegetables and help winemakers by biting
into their grapes and jump-starting
fermentation
this feast continues until autumn when
the foundress changes course she begins
grooming some eggs into a new generation
of Queens while also laying on
fertilized eggs that will mature into
reproductive males called drones this
new crop of Queens and males requires
more food but with summer over the usual
sources run dry and the foraging wasps
start taking more aggressive risks by
September the hives organization
deteriorates hungry workers no longer
clean the nest and various scavengers
just when it seems the hive can no
longer sustain itself the Fertile Queens
and their drones depart in a massive
swarm as the day's grow colder the
workers starve and our queen reaches the
end of her lifespan but above a swarm of
reproductive wasps has successfully made
it the male's die off shortly after but
the newly fertilized Queens are ready to
find shelter for their long sleep and
this wood pile looks like the perfect
place to spend the winter over one third
of America's food is produced
thanks to bees pollinating its crops but
in the past decade bees have been
disappearing at an alarming rate where
have all the bees gone and what happens
if they're gone for good
learn more about the phenomenon known as
colony collapse disorder with this video
[Music]